I am jean-francois and I am a real
tennis player Jean yo yes so I love
possibility but for Jean like which is
slightly disturbing dream Frances my
companion it's like I mean it's like a
snowshoe yes because this isn't if I
played you in the old game yeah
I have bigger hands yeah the antigen it
feels so English doesn't yeah my tennis
is such an English sport because it's
just like it rains I mean I know the
night this cuz yeah although Royal
tennis
so it does rain now yeah okay
it's not showing up so Chris I challenge
you to rap about French Revolution every
names first or second album
marshallmatters and the passion of
lemonade for what reason let's go yo I
wanna tell your what I mean everybody
rise up let's go kill the Queen use a
guillotine put it in a basket got a
question revolution I'll ask it we're
gonna be like lay miserably I'm gonna
take her out of the marble palace yeah
we go I wanna draw a thing yeah my rat
you know marette David they did the
picture is the painting I know she's not
a queen but it is the same thing they
were like ruling the country they'd be
like revolt we don't want none of ye
storm the Bastille steal all the
prisoners away you can fight live for
another day
get the barricades in the small places
Amelia in Paris or races come together I
don't even know let me keep going and
conserve the flow I'm gonna do this
never be silly I want to talk about the
lost I feel for water lilies why in the
first person I say because I add up the
character of Claude Monet I don't have
the accent cuz it makes it harder to rap
it might cause me such a pallava but
here we go
I hit hard and harden again I paint
water lilies in my garden I did so many
things doing Impressionists me that
means all plum air you see in the plein
air a translated bilingual I release
this like it is a great single what
would you get
let me all know talk about a medieval
best in the show they'd be like him that
was the Pernell on the track it might
not be true if you watch this back I'm
just taking from my head yeah my name is
the real Slim Shady and I just say this
stand up Eminem it's the Marshall
Mathers LP that's who I be friend I was
listening to that at 12 years old and
saying Slim Shady is the hip hop gold
marshall mathers yo he not absurd
getting his number in the line he the
third released in this I see the
numerals bland landline you can combine
an ultimate to em in his name if you put
it like this go into Detroit and just
show this coming it out buying it in the
millions I ended up there change like a
chameleon thank you thank you thank you
very much for some excellent words they
were challenging